OK, so we're continuing to talk about testing
and Donald Trump has now confirmed that he
was not kidding when he said slow down Corona
virus testing.
The White House has been tripping all over
itself for days to say Trump was just joking.
Trump was then asked, were you joking?
And he said, I don't kid.
And yet the White House just keeps saying,
oh, he's kidding.
He's kidding.
This is borderline criminal and it's definitely
murderous.
And I want to be sure that you have all of
the facts to understand this story.
So I'm instead of going through this story,
however else I might do it.
I'm going to go through the story chronologically
for you.
OK.
So the start of the story is the United States
failed on corona virus testing from day one
of the U.S. and South Korea got our first
cases at the same time within hours of each
other.
We didn't develop a test quickly.
We didn't roll out a test quickly.
We didn't contact tracing isolate.
South Korea did.
They dominated the virus.
We are leading in cases and deaths.
So that's like the quick summary that gets
us to Saturday, Saturday at his Corona rally
in Tulsa, Oklahoma.
Trump admitted for the first time I told them
to do less testing in order to find fewer
cases.
This is from Saturday.
Test of what you do.
Testing.
To that extent, you can find more people.
You got to find more cases.
So I said to my people, slowed the testing
down, please.
They tests and they test.
We had tests that people don't know what's
going on.
We got tests, we got another one over here.
So this is, of course, completely outrageous.
It's a president admitting that for political
reasons, he asked for something that leads
to more death.
The White House reaction was he was just kidding.
Spokes people said it was just a joke.
Representatives said it was sarcasm.
So then on Monday, Joe St. George interviews
Trump and asks him, did you order Corona virus
testing to be slowed down?
Trump doesn't really answer the question,
but he does say a lot of words.
Take a look.
On Saturday night, you said that you told
your staff to slow the testing down to improve
the numbers.
Does that mean someone watching this right
now on their local news is not going to get
a test?
Because you asked.
We do more testing than any country in the
world by far.
Twenty five million tests.
Other countries do one million.
Every time you do a test, as you do more tests,
it shows more and more cases.
So we're so far advanced both in terms of
the quality and the amount that we're doing
all these tests.
And it shows cases.
If other countries aren't doing or if we did
slow it down, we wouldn't show nearly as many
cases.
So here, Trump doesn't deny that he asked
for less testing.
He simply says if we did less testing, we'd
have fewer cases.
And again, reporters ask the White House and
the Trump campaign that he really ordered
testing to be slowed down because he didn't
deny it.
He was given the chance by Joe St George to
deny it, and he did not deny it.
And the White House, again says it's a joke.
The campaign says he was kidding, et cetera,
et cetera.
So finally yesterday, Donald Trump has asked
straight up.
Were you kidding?
Because people are saying you were kidding.
And Trump says, I don't kid.
I don't get.
Let me just tell you, let me make it clear.
We have got the greatest testing program anywhere
in the world.
So Trump goes into the same talking point
again.
But the key phrase is, I don't kid.
He was not kidding when he asked for testing
to be slowed down.
He was not kidding when he said that he asked
for testing to be slowed down.
Are they also going to say that him saying
he doesn't kid was a form of kidding, like
what's left at this point from this crumbled
attempt, the defense of Donald Trump, he's
given chance after chance.
He's presented with opportunity after opportunity
to improve his answer like it's a do over,
in a sense.
And he just restates what he said on Saturday
night.
He could clarify, oh, well, you know, I meant
this other thing.
He doesn't change it at all because it's the
truth.
It's like being allowed to retake a test.
After you're given all the answers and you
still put down all the same wrong answers
from when you first took the test, I got an
e-mail saying, David, is this is this a confession
to negligent homicide? Trump is admitting
that he asked for something to be done, which
he thought would be good politically.
Which leads to more deaths.
I mean, maybe I just don't even think this
is the right direction to go.
Like, Trump is not going to be held criminally
liable in any way here.
We essentially have you know, I mean, it's
kind of depressing.
But for for a couple years now, I've been
saying November 3rd, 2020, is when we will
have the opportunity to give him a consequence.
We're talking about him like he's a little
boy who's misbehaved because essentially that's
how he behaves.
The it wasn't going to be the Russia investigation.
It wasn't going to be impeachment.
It's not going to be removal under the 25th
Amendment by his cabinet for being unfit.
The opportunity for a consequence is November
3rd.
And all of these disasters and tragedies are
valid reasons to remove him.
And hopefully we will do it because it's really
the only opportunity
that
we have.